[Musica]
quello che vi dirò non fa parte di una
cultura di qualcosa che ho letto ma è la
mia esperienza di vita alla pari credo
noi nasciamo tutti con un talento
latente quello che vi hanno detto c'è
chi ha talento non ha talento avrebbero
dovuto dire c'è chi ha coltivato il
talento e chi non lo coltiva la crescita
di ognuno di noi è inimmaginabile
al di là di ogni possibile aspirazione è
un regalo che abbiamo ricevuto immenso e
che dobbiamo esserne coscienti in realtà
non abbiamo questa percezione
perché la cultura su questo tema non
dice quasi mai la verità ci sono stati
due grandi personaggi che l'hanno detta
ma con una frase è uno stand e l'altro
thomas alva edison che hanno detto
qualcosa di molto simile che juan
percent inspiration ma in piena entra
aspiration sia 1 per cento ispirazione
99 traspirazione sudore e questa è la
realtà
la realtà è che dobbiamo conquistarci
allertamento
tutti abbiamo questa possibilità
io l'ho detto ieri da bambino ero
ossessionato da una paura quella di non
essere in grado ad essere ad arrivare ad
avere il livello degli altri quindi la
mia preoccupazione era quella di
sopravvivere dopo che i miei genitori
non ci fossero spostati ed era una
percussione grande che avevo e il
percorso è stato diverso dalle
previsioni e come avvenuto è avvenuto
col fatto che mi preparavo a lavorare di
più per conquistarmi per arrivare allo
stesso livello di tutti e quindi quello
che ho fatto l'ho fatto con grandissimo
entusiasmo e con grande determinazione
che cos'ha scoperto poi ho scoperto che
c'è un meccanismo che noi abbiamo di cui
non parla nessuno e che è la capacità di
diventare di acquisire un automatismo
ossia l'automatismo cos'è una proprietà
che abbiamo tutti di agire senza pensare
strano però vi farò degli esempi perché
questa vostra perplessità di 20
certezza chi sa guidare la macchina sa
che noi possiamo guidare pensando ad
altro nel senso uno può essere preso da
una discussione in macchina o anche al
telefono completamente preso e la mani i
piedi vanno dove devono andare
la freccia scatta tutto in automatico
ecco questa è già una prova che abbiamo
tutti questo automatismo ma ce n'è un
altro che ancora più importante perché
riusciamo a fare qualche cosa che
nell'antica roma
potevano fare sette persone otto persone
che erano considerate i geni se questa
gente
lavorava per la per i passanti che gli
davano dei soldi per che imprigiona siro
nella carta le parole parole che
potevano essere rilette anche dopo due
mesi 2 anni si chiedono ormai ferme e
queste persone erano gli scrivani
nessuno poteva prevedere che un giorno
avremmo potuto scrivere tutti e come è
stato come ci siamo arrivati
allora consideriamo infatti
che adesso noi non scriviamo con uno
sforzo mnemonico se dobbiamo scrivere
casa non è che dobbiamo pensare alla c
poi alla la s no in automatico scriviamo
tutto in automatico quindi siamo
diventati tutti geni
no però abbiamo tutti appreso qualche
cosa che potevano fare i geni e quante
cose adesso potremmo fare che non
abbiamo fatto questa è la domanda vera
che cosa possiamo riuscire a fare a
creare ognuno di noi cosa incredibile
inimmaginabile attraverso l'automatismo
ossia acquisire col tempo la passione la
cultura la didattica anni e anni con
passione anni anni di notizie di
esperienze alla quale poi possiamo
ricorrere senza quasi neanche pensarci
come sono diventato autore io
ecco questa è la cosa io sono sta
diventato autore attraverso sono stato
assunto come impiegato di terza
categoria era in realtà era un compiuti
compieta non c'erano quindi io ero una
specie di computer vivente scrivevo un
librone grande così con le cifre delle
canzoni dei diritti delle canzoni facevo
questo lavoro molto noioso anche per non
lo facevo con di vicenza poi
ero impiegato in questa edizione è
cominciato a vedere le traduzioni che
facevano le versioni mi sono
appassionato che cominciavo correggerle
poi piano piano ho cominciato a farle mi
davano due euro e cinquanta di allora di
25 mila lì e dire che corrispondono a
250 e io ne facevo 23 al giorno e
scrivevo e questo scrivere questo
cambiare anche la versione perché non è
che faceva sempre il testo originale
io ho avuto spesso lo cambiavo quando
non mi piaceva quando pensavo un un si
capiva bene o non era non esprimeva
quello che diceva la musica e lo
cambiamo e avuto delle grandi successi
anche senza luce per esempio la canzone
che è diventata molto famosa che
italiano
addirittura lo cambiavo ho cambiato
space oddity di un grande cantante
autore david bowie e l'ho fatto
diventare un altro test per la gente ero
convinto che lui
praticamente se convinto l'ha cantato in
italiano quindi ha fatto il disco in
italiano e quindi credo che le sia
piaciuto e conquista continuo
allenamento ho assorbito la capacità
metrica quindi metri che cosa vuol dire
che ogni due
ogni due sillabe c'è un accento diverso
per cui bisogna stare attenti che tutte
le parole corrispondano gli accenti
giusti poi ci sono le rime poi c'è la
difficoltà a alla sintesi al fatto che
ogni parola deve essere capita
velocissimamente al fatto che il testo
di poche parole abbia un senso al fatto
che alla musica corrisponda un testo che
dice la stessa cosa per cui se la musica
diventa in tema
adesso deve essere intimo se cresce ci
vuole una ragione perché cresca quindi o
una meccanica complessa così difficile
veramente che già cercare di arrivare a
finire un fondo che stia in qualche modo
abbia senso era già una una cosa così
difficile io l'ho acquisita nel tempo
negli anni come un automatismo per cui
adesso io sono libero perché tutto
questo è stato già costruito in una
parte del mio cervello e mi lascia
libero di fare tutto quello che poi per
esprimermi perché funziona funziona nel
senso il meccanismo si mette in azione e
agisce indipendentemente dalla fatica e
agisce ma questo non è un privilegio che
ho avuto io ce l'avete tutti così come
scrivete tutti e allora perché non siete
diventati pittori perché non siete
diventati o non avete approfondito una
una parte del una qualsiasi creatività
semplicemente secondo me perché non
sapevate che avevate questa possibilità
che esiste perché è vero due cose sono
vere
una che esiste il genio genio però c'è
qualcosa che riguarda una persona su 5 6
7 8 10 milioni di persone e poi si
rivela in giovanissima età io ho
conosciuto due geni e tutti e due non ha
4 anni se ho cominciato a fare delle
cose incredibili e l'altro assa 5 mezzo
6 quindi
e qualcosa che è rara rarissima però si
può arrivare ad avere ea creare cose di
grande qualità anche senza essere geni
qui a lavorare di più però anche i cigni
devono applicarsi molto dopo quando
hanno già capito il potenziale
straordinario che hanno e poi c'è una
certa predisposizione no
qualcuno riesce più facilmente ad
affrontare però anche questo non è che
chi ha la precipitazione poi riesca
sicuramente più di un altro non è così
tutto si conquista mentre si va verso la
vetta sia passo dopo passo si arriva a
8.000 metri per la continuare a
camminare
quindi abbiamo davanti un orizzonte
incredibilmente ricco di possibilità
il corso è sapere che c'è che si può
fare
e tutto questo lo ha detto ai bambini
perché i bambini giustamente se gli di
te ma tu hai delle qualità poi credi di
poter fare lui riuscivano giustamente
perché non lo può sapere perché il
nostro noi tutti siamo come un terreno
un terreno incolto
allora cosa scusa può produrre un
terreno incolto erbacce cespugli di rovi
ma lo stesso
il terreno coltivato da un contadino
esperto appassionato che ha cominciato
da giovane a fare gli orti può diventare
uno spettacolo miracoloso pomodori
meravigliosi peperoni tutto zucchine
tutto ed è lo stesso terreno che faceva
solo erbacce
io credo che sia importante che voi
crediate quello che ha detto ma non per
me per voi
arrivederci
[Applauso]
[Musica]